you might have thought he would stay
quiet he's doing exactly the opposite
amazing what he said today exactly the
opposite a live chat today at the
Guardian website from Edward Snowden
again one of the most controversial
people in the world today responded to a
variety of questions about his
disclosures of US government secrets on
these surveillance programs asked more
about his motivations here are some
highlights he was asked about being
called a traitor by among others dick
cheney and here was his response part of
his response this is a man who gave us
the warrantless wiretapping scheme is a
kind of atrocity warm up on the way to
deceitfully engineering a conflict that
has killed over 4,400 and maim nearly
32,000 americans as well as leaving over
100,000 Iraqis dead being called a
traitor by Dick Cheney is the highest
honor you can give an American again
Edward Snowden at least someone claiming
to be Edward Snowden responding on the
Guardian website another highlight here
on China whether he plans to provide
classified information to the Chinese in
exchange for asylum he responds to that
question as well during the course of
this live chat he says in that response
this is a predictable smear that I
anticipated before going public as the
US media has a knee-jerk Red China
reaction to anything involving HK Hong
Kong or the People's Republic of China
and it is intended to distract from the
issue of US government misconduct asked
yourself if I were a Chinese spy why
wouldn't I have flown directly into
Beijing I could be living in a palace
petting a Phoenix by now he says
unequivocally he's had no contact with
the Chinese government and Snowden also
weighing in on the technology companies
who say they're not giving unfettered
access to the federal government to the
to their servers they're actively of
course trying to distance themselves
from the government he says again as
somewhat of a shot against these
companies their denials went through
several revisions as it became becomes
more and more clear they were misleading
and included identical specific language
across companies we're finally beginning
to see more transparency better details
about these programs for the first time
since their inception they are legally
compelled to comply and maintain their
silence in regard to specifics of the
program that does not comply them from
ethical obligations so some of the
highlights from Edward Snowden's nearly
two-hour response to the public during
the course of that live chat on the
Guardian website